flattened buildings and mountains of
concrete the aftermath of a 5.6
magnitude earthquake that struck the
island of java dozens of people have
been killed and hundreds injured as
Rescuers search for survivors
homes were not built to withstand the
force of a quake like this
[Music]
I was crying and immediately grabbed my
husband and children if I didn't pull
them out we might have become victims
the house was shaking as if it was
dancing
it struck near the town of chenjur in
the middle of the day the local Governor
says schools were hit hard and most of
those killed were children
field hospitals have been set up in the
streets everywhere survivors in the
middle of this chaotic crowded community
most suffered a broken bone or were
injured because of falling objects and
incision wounds and there were also
around 13
784 evacuees
Crews worked through the night to save
lives there's been dozens of aftershocks
and access is difficult in remote areas
with roads blocked by landslides people
embracing themselves for a large number
of dead
foreign
this country is no stranger to
earthquakes it's in an area known as the
Pacific Ring of Fire one of the most
active regions in the world for volcanic
eruptions and tremors
the trauma of this one will linger as
the enormity of This Disaster sinks in
Nicole Johnston Sky News